but even the research here they're
monkeying around with bird flu and all
these different flues that are very
contagious and they're like saying well
it's really deadly but it's not
aerosolized let's try to make it
aerosolized let's try to adapt this
deadly virus that doesn't spread very
easily let's see if we can make it
spread as you're it's a death wish
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today from
Washington DC is the just re-elected
senator from the great state of Kentucky
Rand Paul welcome to the as you called
it the the dungeon Reuben report glad to
be with you all right so when we booked
this trip we knew we were going to do
something post-election we thought there
was going to be some sort of Red Wave
thought you guys were going to be in
charge of the Senate can we pretend like
we're still before the election and
there still is the possibility of Redway
did not work out that way how you
feeling you know uh with my race very
good we got the highest percentage we've
ever gotten I got about 62 two percent
in most of our rural counties we got
between 70 and 80 percent we had 10
counties we got more than 85 percent of
the vote 10 counties more than 80
percent probably all together about 50
counties more than 70 percent of the
vote so that kind of shows a little bit
of what's going on nationally that was
from rural counties we do very well in
Rural America not so well in urban
America so we have two cities in
Kentucky Louisville and Lexington that
are of any kind of significant size we
lose those 60 40.
um but I think that's that's part of the
answer to you know how we do around the
country you see we win the geography we
just don't win the population
necessarily how long do you think that
can hold when people look at the map and
they see basically an 80 to 90 percent
seemingly red map and then they see the
population centers that are blue
detention between those two areas well
um something's got to give but it were
basically just about evenly divided I
mean it's hard to believe you can have
an election in Georgia and there's an
almost even amount I mean almost exactly
even amount of people on either side of
the divide and I think people are voting
more just which tribe they think they
belong to
um people say oh it's about candidate
quality well frankly Dr Oz was a great
candidate he I've seen him campaign he's
a great retail campaigner who's on
daytime TV you know for goodness for a
decade or more he's very good with
people and very likable very intelligent
can answer all the questions and uh so I
don't think it was he was defeated
because he wasn't quality of candidate I
think it's that we're in sort of these
separate camps and they are different
camps but frankly it's interesting when
I meet people almost anybody who's
working is in our cap I mean so it's
interesting you go into a machine shop
and 10 guys have grease on their hands
they're as Republican as you come and
they're not very uh considerate of
people who don't work in fact they're
disdainful people who don't work but we
also have a labor force participation
where 38 percent of our country doesn't
work so that's a huge block of Voters
there there's also a huge block of
government voters in fact I think the 87
000 IRS agents is is more about politics
than it is about harassing us sure
they'll harass us that's a given and I
don't want them but I think it's really
about 87 000 more voters in Virginia
maybe not all of them but a lot of them
would be in Northern Virginia that could
tip the balance even so literally just
moving people from wherever to Virginia
just to take this job because it's so
close employed for a long time for
government there's a tendency to say
well you know deficit is kind of a
problem but then again they pay me
really well so uh so you see how
government workers gradually kind of
shift over to the Democrat Party and
most of the Three Counties you know just
on the other side of the Potomac River
are very are very Democrat but they're
all federal government workers if you
grow the federal government you make it
harder to for a republican to win
Virginia is that your biggest
frustration as probably the most
Libertarian Senator that we have that
people just in the end of the day
despite quality candidate quality or
anything else they kind of just want
more stuff sadly well it is and I talk
about it a lot you know when I when I
talk to Folks at home and around the
country it's that what we're offering is
intangible we're offering the
opportunity we're offering Freedom the
Allure of what comes with it one that
you're left alone to do whatever the
heck you want to do but also the great
Prosperity comes with freedom but it's
an intangible it's not a concrete the
other side's offering you a cell phone
you want a cell phone you want the
government to buy you a cell phone you
want the government to pay for your
college you want the government to pay
for your housing and your food and so
they're offering something and it's the
Allure of something for nothing and the
people working for it are frustrated by
it the people receiving are like that's
not too bad maybe I could use more maybe
I could have what about Universal basic
income you know so so if if things had
gone a little bit differently and the
senate had had broke red would you be
licking your chops right now figuring
out what to do with fauci and figuring
out we still are going to try it's uh
it's obviously not ideal but I'm going
to try hard to convince the Democrats I
sent I don't know if you read Nicholas
Wade's article in medium this came out
about a year ago and it was the the
article that awoke everybody I hadn't
even paid much attention to the lab leak
until I read his article it's like 40 50
page article no one would touch it the
none of the mainstream media he printed
it on medium which is a self-publication
but it's incredibly well done he's
written for nature science New York
Times science writer and he writes this
and it's just an amazing reveal of how
um the science points towards this
coming from the lab and that there has
been a cover-up
um so anyway I sent that article to
Leading Democrats on homeland security
that has the oversight to investigate
this with the hope that maybe one of
them will read it and go my God we
should investigate this or this could
happen again
um so is that hope stand right now I
mean does anyone you send them these
things does anyone care does anyone I've
tried for two years to get any kind of
hearing and have not had any luck but I
think some of it is it became very
public the school wobble with Dr fauci
and he became the Paragon of government
and they the Democrats love governments
they don't want to be attacking
government but the really the the look
into the virus's origins isn't an attack
of Biden in fact most of this happened
under the Trump Administration frankly
and and under the Maybe Obama
administration but letting go of gain of
function letting gain of function
research get started again really there
was a pause and I think they were
disobeying the pause but then really it
happened under the Trump Administration
I don't think Trump had any idea what
was going on but it did happen during
his administration so it really isn't
pointing fingers at one president or the
other it's really about getting to the
bottom of this so this doesn't happen
again so even if you had this edit and
you were in charge of the committee that
was you know putting fauci out there and
dealing with all of that it's not like
much happens after right I think that's
one of the things people are always
confused about like we have these
hearings then does anything ever
actually people want something you know
people in the Trump rally say lock them
up you know they want somebody locked up
and Frank give you a lot of Congress if
you're a republican they do lock you up
if you're a Democrat they ignore you
right but I don't have any
um I guess naive hopes that that would
happen if you did lie and if out she
lied yes you should go to jail but they
control the doj and so I see that but
here's my hope is still this even in the
minority in the Senate my hope is to win
the argument convince the public and
then do something about it and that
doesn't mean necessarily someone goes to
jail what it means is that we regulate
gain and function research our tax
dollars number one shouldn't go to Wuhan
China period I don't even if they're you
know just trying to discover penicillin
I wouldn't send them the money to do it
because I don't trust them and we don't
have any money we're borrowing it from
them to send it to them so it doesn't
make any sense so I wouldn't send any
money to most foreign countries for
research let's do some research here but
even the research here they're monkeying
around with bird flu and all these
different flues that are very contagious
and they're like saying well it's really
deadly but it's not aerosolized let's
try to make it aerosolized let's try to
adapt half there's deadly virus that
doesn't spread very easily let's see if
we can make it spread easier it's a
death wish so we did have one
subcommittee hearing and I had three
scientists come in they're not partisans
I don't even know their political
persuasion in fact I think some of them
lean Democrat one from Rutgers one from
MIT and one who's a a not Tech
entrepreneur all three of them came to
Independent conclusions and they said
this kind of research needs to be
regulated by an independent agency like
the nuclear regulatory agency so for
example if you're making uh centrifuges
in your basement in Miami you're not
allowed to sell them to Iran yeah right
guys we're going to have fun yeah so and
as much as I'm not for a lot of
government rules I am for that that's
for National Security you shouldn't be
able to make you know Atomic weapons and
sell them to people you know or make the
ingredients every libertarian has their
limit okay we just got yours you can't
build your own nukes okay that's my
arm's limit but I would have the same
kind of limits on DNA if we make DNA
synthesizers and you can create a virus
out of just the particles of it so
really is there and a virus can't
survive without a host but really you
they can create life now we can create
any virus we want to and they can put it
together put the parts together and then
all it has to do is enter into a cell
and it's alive it takes over the cell
and uses the cell to be alive but we
create them out of nothing and all you
need is the map and so we should be
regulating that the machines that do it
the machines that
um help them to recombine the virus and
maybe some of the animals so we have
these bizarre things these hybrid
animals that are are chimeric animals
they have mice that have human lungs so
what you do is you put a batch of virus
in there that's that doesn't infect
humans really well and you put it in and
almost all of it dies but a little bit
of it lives and then you run it through
again and again serial passage until it
adapts to the human lungs you're like oh
hey we made this virus that doesn't
infect humans we select It Out by
pushing Evolution Evolution could
randomly
something switches and becomes infected
human it's unlikely but it can happen
this way you force it to evolve by
continuing to run it through uh human
lungs that are in mice you can force it
to evolve in a direction to make it more
adaptable to humans and that's what
people think this thing came out of the
lab and boom it was incredibly
infectious to humans and the thing that
one of the strongest arguments is it
won't affect bats
we can't find an animal that is a native
host to this
and they think almost all the
coronaviruses come from bats well how
did this thing get so distant from baths
so quickly without us seeing it
somewhere else in the population for a
year smoldering nobody has antibodies to
this till boom 2020 and then everybody
gets it basically you're giving me the
beginning of the zombie movie right
that's where this whole thing goes so
essentially and this and this realized
the world went nuts complete mostly
Democrat Governors but even Republicans
went nuts on this thing look at that
beating the crap out of people in China
locking people in their homes this death
rate was point three percent in the end
it wasn't nothing it wasn't nothing to
sneeze at but point three percent there
are viruses that they're monkeying
around with and at 15 30 even 50
mortality where half the world would die
can you imagine the freak out when one
gets out of a lab that has a 50
mortality what were you doing in
Kentucky like that first two weeks
because I always say on my show I grant
everybody sort of a complete leash for
those first two weeks when we had no
idea what was going on and even DeSantis
who really came out as the hero of this
thing he did lock down in essence for
two weeks and then reversed but as as
the Liberty guy what were you doing and
what kind of pressure you never favored
the lockdowns and I didn't vote for any
of the money I didn't vote for one penny
of the coveted money because I always
thought the choice was the Republicans
said well for shutting down the economy
we have to give people money we can't we
can't just do that and I said well maybe
we could reconsider shutting down the
economy so I never was in favor of the
lockdowns and I you know had hoped that
maybe Trump would do it temporarily but
Trump succumbed as much as he was
portrayed as a strong character he never
fired fauci and his people kept saying
you fire him you lose the election well
he lost the election and didn't fire
fouchy maybe he should have fired fauci
early on and uh fauci Burks they were
all you know big government people with
decisions every day they had a different
opinion almost none of it was based on
science and still to this day they won't
acknowledge that natural immunity works
if you've had the infection you have
some protection this isn't to deny
vaccines they both work vaccines work
and so does natural immunity and
actually the combination of it's why
people aren't as afraid of this disease
anymore but it's also why as they start
to mandate coveted vaccines on children
that we should say well hey my kid
already had covered does he really need
a Cove vaccine shouldn't I get that
choice and the question I keep asking if
my kids already had covid what is the
chance that he goes to the hospital and
dies with a second bout of covet it's
probably zero in fact I haven't seen a
case where a kid had coveted unless the
child is very very sick from some other
disease and almost all the children that
died under 18
who were very very sick and sadly we're
dying from some other disease there was
nobody there were no like healthy
children like oh my you know healthy 10
year olds playing in the yard gets gov
and die didn't happen and so we
shouldn't be forcing the vaccine on them
particularly because there are some side
effects to the vaccine for children
particularly boys between the ages of 16
and 24 which just happened to be a lot
of the kids in our military the young
men in our military are at risk for
heart inflammation and that risk exceeds
easily their risk for any kind of
problems and then of course Dr aladipo
in Florida the Surgeon General puts out
that report and then Twitter censors it
which is a whole other thing about
censorship but I know you're tied on
time so let me just ask you one other
thing so as we're taping this on Tuesday
supposedly Trump may make some sort of
announcement tonight obviously the big
thing right now in the Republican party
is which way is this thing going to go
is it going to be a trump party or
perhaps a disant this party I know you
you founded one of the Liberty caucus
right with uh with Ron Ron DeSantis
early on we were allies of here I knew
him something from the Congressional
baseball game he was a good baseball
player he played at Yale and I can
remember him coming to one of the early
practices and hitting a home run during
practice which is you know for a bunch
of old guys out there playing it was
pretty impressive
um so he was a good player but he ended
up having shoulder surgery at that time
and didn't really play on the team and
then he ran for governor so I don't know
him real well but I have met him I've
been impressed with what he's done the
other thing is it is about who you hire
in your Administration the fact that
he's put forward this this Public Health
Doctor Who is talented like it is and
telling the truth and is not just an
apologist for big government and
unafraid uh such that he's got big Tech
alarm I'm I'm pretty impressed with that
what would you want to happen there I'm
not asking you for who do you like more
but in terms of do you want them if it's
going to happen to battle it out
publicly or would you rather it sort of
be dealt with probably because there's
just so many fights it seems like right
now in the Republicans always it's funny
how people come to politics like well
why don't you just step aside David I'll
do it and uh or you come to me and say
well you know I would be better at the
center of Kentucky why don't you just
step episode and you can sort of give me
some advice no one ever does that so it
never really works behind the scenes so
what happens is if people have it inside
them and and people in politics aren't
shrinking violence they they believe
they have some of the answers and I
think Trump would fall into that
category I think DeSantis would fall
into that category I think there's a
half dozen others if I had to guess and
this is just a guess
um I think today Trump's going to
announce that's probably not a fairly
easy guess and then I think that uh at
some point in time DeSantis will
announce as well but I think once
there's two then I think it'll be hard
to hold back some of the others I think
there will be a pens I think there'll be
a Pompeo
um I you know they've all said they
would run against back in the mix yeah I
don't know but uh I do think that there
will be a mix though and for me the
decision will be on who is the least
likely to get us involved in war a lot
of them will be fiscally conservative uh
some of them I think are
um you know much more inclined to be
involved in foreign war much more
aggressive I mean they'd send my kids to
Ukraine tomorrow most of them and I
think Trump a little less actually and
Trump leans a little more independent or
libertarian on the war issue and that
used to be something that could bring
new people into the fold but now the
progressives in our country are more
hyped up on going to war in Ukraine than
just about anybody in the world I mean
they really are ready now they're
they're not ready to fight themselves
but they're damn sure ready to send your
kid to Ukraine and the fact that we
already have soldiers in Ukraine and
nobody's really talking about it just
sort of silently happened oh they're
just advisors they're just counting the
weapons they're there to have oversight
you know it's like yeah until one of
them's skilled or a couple of them are
killed and then we're in the war plus
the blank check that you tried to get
some receipts on we'll we'll keep
waiting for those receipts Senator I
appreciate your time thank you thanks if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell